Outside of the metastasis question, would blood tests be recommended?
Absolutely. So doing blood tests to, so what kind of blood tests should be done on a regular
basis? A CBC, which will measure red blood cell count, make sure you don't have any type of
ademia going on will be really good. A complete metabolic panel, so complete metabolic panel would
measure like your liver function tests, make sure that everything's working well there.
That those are your two most common things to do as far as blood tests go. And then if you want to
get into do looking at two remarkers, you are, that's those are more specific tests. But your CBC and
complete metabolic panel, that'd be the standard thing you'd get done is if you went and got a,
you know, your your annual checkup, they would do that with a very minimal. If uses two
remarkers would only be for someone who has a history of cancer. Do Google or Google, sorry, do
search on that little search bar for two remarkers. And you'll see my blog post about two remarker tests
to get specific on what two remarkers might be appropriate for you to run, depending on your cancer.
And then there's other things that you might run. So other blood tests like if you're, you might
want to get a complete thyroid panel. You might want to get a complete lipid panel. So if you're
concerned about, you know, your cholesterol balance and triglycerides and things like that,
those are the other things that you could.